it seems we are bound to repeat history
and what as old becomes new again why is
it that we can't seem to find
equilibrium within a society ideas begin
with good intentions but lead towards
the extreme yeah well the reason we
can't find equilibrium is because the
environment that we live in isn't an
equilibrium and so I I kind of imagined
it this way it's like we're we're
traversing the back of a giant this is
obviously a symbolic reference of the
giant serpent and it's it weaves back
and forth and you don't know at any
moment which way it's gonna curve and
turn and so sometimes it turns to the
right and sometimes it turns to the left
and what that means politically is that
sometimes we have to turn to the right
and sometimes we have to turn to the
left and we don't know exactly Windows
what would you call we don't know
exactly how to time that and so what we
all have to do is keep our eyes open and
tell the truth and discuss things with
each other especially with people who
have political beliefs that are
different than us so that we can ensure
that we haven't tilted too far one way
or the other and that's why I'm an
advocate of free speech or one of the
many reasons I'm an advocate of free
speech is because it's the continual
dialogue between people of different
temperamental types that keeps us
oriented as close as we can to the
center of the Serpent's back and so
there is no permanent equilibrium
there's only the equilibrium that's
produced by continual negotiation and a
democracy is a formalized negotiation
and so and and and it's free speech that
keeps it healthy and alive so there's no
permanent equivalent equilibrium state
except death no and it's always
negotiation in relationships to like if
you have an intimate relationship or a
familial relationship or even a
friendship there's no final equilibrium
state you have to communicate with each
other honestly all the time and keep the
relationship moving to adjust the
environment that the relationship is
operating in that's how it stays alive
in an intimate long-term intimate
relationship like a marriage it's a
continual it takes continual effort
I mean it's worthwhile effort and that
but you have to be conscious in a way to
keep your relationship alive and you
have to be
communicating all the time well maybe
not all the time because you can over
communicate too but so well so that's
why we can't reach a state of permanent
equilibrium